yeah we had this bug where things just
went like
things weren't um behaving well when we
were deleting like uh entities so i want
to fix that because it's a little bit
annoying and i had a quick look at it
last night and i couldn't solve it so
this will be interesting to turn into a
little bit of a video or a stream or
something like that
um
yeah i'm gonna just light my little
contraption those of you don't know i
have this lovely like frying like cast
iron skillet style frying pan with like
a tea light underneath it and then
there's like some stuff that it's
melting just gonna go ahead and
introduce that to the stream
uh so i gotta light that so i'll be back
i managed to create some fire
it's lit it's gonna
it's gonna fry nicely
and we're gonna
get on with some
some nice
duck hunting i mean bug hunting so
um as i mentioned i actually have no
idea why this is happening and i wasn't
lying
uh this isn't gonna be like one of those
fake little i have no idea what's going
on but really it's just all a show no
unfortunately i wish that was the case
because that would make my life easier
but no
i actually don't know what's happening
so um basically this is the bug i'll
show you guys the bug so that you're
you're aware of the bug but basically
the bug is uh every time i say the bug
by the way you have to take a shot of
um of orange juice because this is a pg
stream right
so
um yeah so basically the problem is that
if we try and delete sponsor there's
actually a few bugs like for example
sometimes i can't click on stuff here
sometimes stuff just disappears this
scene hierarchy panel has a few bugs
happening which is a bit annoying but
anyway like look at this i can't even
select this what's going on that's what
happens when our audio guy decides to do
ui if i delete this sponsor model
as you can see it does not get deleted
it's gone from here
but
like what is this stuff
it's suddenly gotten bigger possibly
because it's been like unparented or
something and like the thing is it's
kind of weird because
it's still like an entity i can move it
and stuff
uh it's obviously being rendered
it looks like it should be a real thing
and i mean more so if i click on it to
like select it you can see it is
actually appearing here
so the thing is
um it's it seems to be like still in the
entity component system and it still
seems to be like a valid entity and
everything it's just not showing up in
the scene hierarchy panel why isn't it
showing up in the same hierarchy panel
well the way that we actually show
entities in this panel here is kind of
dependent on like the where they are in
terms of their own personal hierarchy of
like parents and children all that stuff
so if they have no valid parent then as
far as i know i think they're not going
to show up in the hierarchy so clearly
deleting that sponsor entity has in fact
left some orphans here but they are
i don't know why they exist so there's a
few few things i want to do to kind of
take a look at this right the first
thing is i don't like the idea of not
knowing what's going on i think that
when you're you know programming and
when you're doing all of this when
you're setting up like
complex things like game engines it's
always really nice to write some tools
for yourself so that you can actually
see what's going on at all times that's
kind of important
and so that's what i'm going to do my
pillow fell over
that's all right it's not visible on
stream anyway so it doesn't matter so
basically what i want to do is i want to
make a new kind of panel
i want to make a new kind of i want to
make like a debug kind of entity
component system panel type deal
and the purpose of this is just to dump
like literally just raw entity
information because clearly something is
surviving and i want to be able to
inspect it as best as i can this
shouldn't take very long
uh i'm just gonna go over here i've
moved my solution explorer to that side
because i think it's less useful than
the code to look at i'm just making some
new files no big deal
so we're going to call this like
ecs panel
because it's just going to this is just
for kind of a debug
and it's just going to be a way
for us to
like move this a bit
um
for us to be able to just dump some info
so let's go ahead and name space
hazelnus
namespace hazel
class ecs panel
um we don't really need to do much so i
will add a like a scene as like a
context
so that we can
see what's up i don't think we really
need that on
i'm going render we'll open
and
we'll obviously keep track of that
context
and maybe like a set context
would also be
appropriate in case we switch scenes to
the run time or whatever all right
so let's quickly make all of this stuff
doing some speed running programming
here
um context context
will have no destructor for now and on
i'm going render so i am going begin
acs
so we'll i guess we'll call this ecs
like debug or something acs debug panel
maybe uh and then we're gonna type in
open like that this is just so that we
can close it and then if it's if open is
false then we just return this is just a
way for us to show the panel and not
show the panel if we don't want to
include hazel ui i am oh hazel i'm going
i'm gooey
all right and set context
um
this will this can just be implemented
here
context context
uh
i'll call this context
i have three eggs we already talked
about that keep up
so
let's see so we've got this panel that's
good so yeah so basically what i want to
do here is copy kind of what the scene
hierarchy panel is doing because it's
doing all it's like rendering all the
entities but um the thing is this is not
going to be a hierarchy and that's kind
of the point i want to just see the raw
view of everything obviously everything
is kind of a flat list it's not really a
hierarchy that doesn't make much sense
well i know i mean i i guess
theoretically it could be but it's not
right because energy component systems
store like just components as like just
arrays so there's no hierarchy there's
no like linked list or some kind of
actual tree data structure it's just a
list it's just like a vector
so if we take a look at like
um
yeah i guess online render and then we
take a look at the scene hierarchy and
context and then what does it do there's
a whole bunch of i'm going code here but
eventually we go through this and you
can see we kind of go through the
registry and we just view all of this
stuff but i actually want to
a better place to start might be the
serializer because the serializer
actually
like takes a look at um
it just actually you know iterates
through every component because it has
to serialize it or every uh entity or
other so where does it do that so
serialize
serialize and then you can see it goes
through every id component so it's
almost perfect
it doesn't go through every component
because what if a component what if
something's missing an id component very
unlikely and i don't think it's
happening here
but still kind of possible i guess but
whatever so
first of all we have to add um
this ecs panel as a friend class because
the registry is
private and then if we come over here
let's just go ahead and go through this
so
m context so
if context just in case it's null in
which case the panel will be blank
we're going to go through this okay so
now we have every single entity so what
i want to do now is very simple i want
to just list it i want to just have a
list of these things for now now we
could have some kind of like table or
whatever i don't really want to do any
of that i just kind of want a selectable
list
of things now
um
now for the selectable list situation we
could have tree i guess there's
something called i'm going selectable
which you can use this is probably a
good time to use it so let's try and get
like a
uh const order name from it which will
be
entity so let's make actually we'll call
this like e
and we'll do entity uh entity equals e
and m context dot
raw
because i think this once
this uses a pointer roll pointer just
because it's we could have used a weak
graph now that we have weak references
but
um
it just uses raw because it's it's not
taking ownership of it it shouldn't be
keeping it alive it's just like a way to
access it so entity.get uh can we just
get name
so we can't do name so i'm just gonna
whoops
accidental russian as usual
uh so we don't have names so i want to
get the name right so
let's go ahead and just do const auto
sorry console city string
name
uh that'll be the const version and that
will be uh scene
registry
get
uh tag component
dot tag
why are you upset
whatever we'll we'll figure out why it's
because it needs this
and then we'll have an unconstitution as
well
in case we want to modify it now i don't
know if entities are guaranteed to have
a tag component that's kind of the issue
and maybe that's why it's not like
might not be a good idea to do
i don't know though entities do they
have to have a tag component well
possibly like i guess yes
because when we create an entity i'm
pretty sure it always
like adds a adds a tag component to it
no we'll actually create child entity if
it doesn't have a tag component
if it doesn't have a name in this case
it doesn't actually add a tag component
so it's possible it doesn't have a tag
component
so let's do this for name um let's just
make a static uh an inline static std
string
uh no name
um
[Music]
which will make uh
no name michael's null i don't know
now's a bit weird but
whatever no yeah because it's not null
it's just unnamed let's just do unnamed
and then what the reason for this is
that we can expand this name
to be a bit a bit better now so we can
do like uh
has
components i don't know why i'm using
this to be honest
so how's component
tag component
so if it has component tag component
then we return get component
tag component dot name
mod.tag
otherwise we return
[Music]
no name
because it returns a reference so we
need to return something valid and yeah
we'll do the same thing here but
obviously it will be const all right
brilliant so
going back to ecs uh panel now we can do
entity name
which is fantastic so now we've got the
name name dot c string
uh and
i mean bull selected like for now we
won't be able to select them i guess but
it would be better to select them in
some form so we probably have to have
like an array of so we'll
we'll select it so this will have an
index and we can just keep track of the
the selected entity i assume so let's
just do like entity
selected entity
that should be an invalid identity by
default um
so i think the way that we well bull
selected is going to equal m selected
entity equals entity
so in that case it's selected now uh we
do have to give it this
because if
we decide that it's now selected right
so if i guess if
that then selected but i don't really
want it to be because it will set
selected to be that and then what are
these selected flags anyway
disabled
allow double click yeah i don't care
about any of this um
so we'll just do zero or whatever and
then there's a size which i also don't
care about so if it's selected
then we'll just do this
like we don't really have to we don't
have to worry about the boolean being
written to
so this just lets us select it right
it's pretty simple and then i don't like
we can't really deselect it
at the moment but i don't care about
that either so we should now be listing
all these names so this is fine but like
um i kind of want to add a little bit
more information to this so like i want
to have the good as well so let's just
do std string
like label and then we'll make this fmt
format so we'll do the name
and then maybe the
id so
name
and uh
entity get uuid
and then this label is what we'll
actually use here
okay so going back to entity uh
editor layer that's what i meant going
back to editor layer let's um go to
where are all of my panels
there's so much stuff here that needs to
be cleaned up optimization october where
are you
so asset manager panel open let's do
like um
ecs panel open
and then i guess like this is lame
though where's like the scene hierarchy
panel where's everything at the moment
we're a little bit all over the place
because we can't like even close these
things but this is like a bunch of
panels
so i guess i'll just make it here um and
then we can make it a scope sure it
doesn't really matter
ecs panel
i have to include that
so ecs panel
we'll call this ecs panel
i'll call it ecs debug panel because it
really should only be used for debugging
like just what we're doing now
yeah so see there's a lot of set contact
stuff that needs to happen so i guess
we'll kind of follow along with this
um
[Music]
and we'll just duplicate the scene
hierarchy panel
except yeah we can pass in uh
a cs debug part acs panel open maybe
i'll just rename that to debug panel
uh set selected wear and care about
i guess it would be nice to select it in
there though yeah that would probably be
nice
let's do that actually so we'll add a
set selected
[Music]
which doesn't exist yet obviously but
um this means that we can actually mouse
pick it
[Music]
so
uh but we won't let it pick us probably
maybe
we could do that though we could try and
click on it and then it was selected and
that would be kind of cool
but i won't i probably won't bother with
that for now
so set context to run time scene
okay good so i'm just making sure that
they're both there basically okay so set
selected isn't a thing ecs
panel
so what we'll do is we'll have a void
set selected
uh and then this is pretty simple uh
this just takes in an entity i think
right and then just sets m selected
entity to entity
and that's probably it and then that
should obviously reflect here so let's
see what we've created
now oh there's no way to open the panel
actually so back in the delay let's go
to view
so we have like a view menu
um begin menu view right and then we can
do like um i might add like a little
separator
because these are like debug panels well
so is asset manager though
uh whatever um
ecs debug
did we give it a title
yeah acs debug wait let's take a look so
this is coming along nicely for those of
you uh playing along
um it's uh mostly melted now
smells amazing it's a pity that i can't
show you guys what it smells like but
you're gonna have to take my word for it
first time catching the stream your boy
nachin how's it going what are we doing
today we're solving some bugs we're bug
hunting
uh we've got a weird bug where sometimes
when i delete like a whole
uh like cluster of entities what's with
this like
i swear it was did not take this long
yesterday because we're in debug so
we're running a bit slowly but anyway
sometimes when we delete stuff it
doesn't delete all of it and it seems to
like do weird things now i have a
feeling i know why but i'm also taking
this as an opportunity to get to get my
uh my crap together
if we take a look at sponsor so this is
the what i'm talking about so if we go
view an ecs debug apparently it's true
already why is it true i thought it was
false by default
oh i can't even uncheck it for some
reason what oh
lol
open
that was weird
so we were um
yeah we were setting the actual like
pointer into the
into the thing so of course it's always
true and by changing it i don't know i
guess we weren't changing it very well i
don't know what's going on there
a little bit weird
because you're supposed to pass in a
boolean which is like one bite and we're
all passing in like a eight byte pointer
so it was probably screwing with the
pointer when we were checking it but it
was true because of course it wasn't
zero anyway
so if we now do ecs debug
so you can see we have like all of our
entities listed out here which is pretty
cool that's exactly what i wanted so
let's just kind of dock this over here
and i'm going to open up that other
scene which should
trigger a yep so it's changed as you can
see it's just loading the meshes and
stuff in the meantime
but it's already loaded the scene
hierarchy which is cool so this is like
a flat list of all of the entities that
we have in our scene right i might just
try and
uh make it a little bit more visible for
you peeps just lining that up with the
face cam so we have um we have all of
these entities right
and uh we should even be able to
it's hard to see because the highlight
color sucks but when i'm clicking on
this you can see it's actually selecting
them here it's almost more visible on
stream um
so uh but i can't if i click it doesn't
select them here but if i select
something over here
uh okay it doesn't work if i selected
the scene haracker panel but if i click
on something in the viewport it selects
it here which is pretty cool so the idea
is right what i'm doing is i'm deleting
this but clearly they're not all being
deleted so let's see what happens this
contains 25 different entities
right so obviously i'd expect like 25 of
these to disappear
but they're not disappearing but anyway
so let's try and delete spawns off
see
we we did delete some but look how many
are left and we can't see any of them
here so see this is nice as like a debug
feature because we've already given
ourselves the ability to be able to see
what is actually going on as a
programmer i want to be aware of the
data because the data is everything so
here is the data and we can see that we
still have these so they didn't get
deleted properly
i don't know why though um it's very
strange because i think another thing i
was doing
uh was i was actually like logging
um something like impossible to bring up
the taskbar sometimes uh yeah so
no this is rubbish i was logging
something else i was logging like all
them being deleted
let's go ahead and okay i want to do a
couple of things actually i want to make
sponsored the startup project so let me
just find like the age proj and we'll
make
uh scenes
sponsor demo i think we'll make that the
startup scene and then if i go into
scene let's go ahead and try to figure
out what's going on so this is the this
is the function of this is the function
that we're
that we're trying to fix right so we
destroy entity and clearly its goal
is to destroy
uh entities and we have the ability to
exclude children which we're not doing
right so we're issuing a command to
destroy entities
this is happening from
i think
uh the
same hierarchy panel now
it's hot well yes but it's happening
from
i'm not sure why it's not popping up can
i
from all projects references from all
program
so here it is so edit a layer destroy
entity this is where it's happening
so
this is the command that's destroying it
this is when we hit the delete key
so it's passing it in with exclude
children as false meaning the children
are included
and then what it's doing is a bunch of
stuff that we don't care about
my can my biggest concern here is that
something is
uh
messing with this list because we're
iterating through this list and we're
recursively deleting all of this stuff
but the thing is if this is messing with
the list
then
you know you have to be careful with 4-h
loops because if within the 4-h loop if
you're modifying the iterator that
you're using it's very bad and most
languages like java and c-sharp will
actually throw like concurrent
modification exceptions or something
like that maybe not concurrent because
that implies kind of multi-threading but
uh it'll they'll have some kind of
exceptions that they throw because like
hey man you can't do this if you have a
regular for loop it's fine usually
because you just have like an index and
you're just accessing it by index but
this can invalidate the iterator if you
modify this now the simplest way to
prove that case because that's kind of
like my first uh
my first guess
is what i could do is copy the list
because if i copy the list
then it doesn't matter what i'm doing
anymore you know i have a copy of it i
can use one copy to iterate over it and
another copy to modify
so again i don't know i don't know if
this is the solution like well first of
all copying is obviously we want to
avoid that if we can but these are just
uuids it's some of the biggest deal in
the world and this is a delete function
which we call like well i mean
throughout gameplay i guess you could be
destroying entities all the time but
at the moment it's just like we're
hitting the delete key and that's it so
let's just see
we're gonna use this as like a test so
auto children equals entity children i'm
just copying this what is this as i
mentioned a vector of uids
so we're copying our children let's
iterate through this copied list
right so the deal is uh when this
actually destroys it it might be it
might be modifying this children list or
something might be happening but it's
not going to be modifying our copy
because it can't
so let's just see if that does anything
i'm not sure that it will because i
don't really see any code i mean we have
removed child ah remove child does
remove something right so it is clearly
erasing something so it's possible to
remove child
is messing with it actually that would
make sense
okay never mind this is beginning to
seem likely
so let's let's see if this is actually
the cause of this you guys can't see
that but she's just she's just chilling
like
you're sitting on my
speaker
what do you want attention again glad
did
that you've got
so she's so needy lately
needs her journal time don't we all
so let's try to delete this so i'll
bring up that ecs debug panel again
let's try delete sponsor oh my gosh
they're all gone
solved okay so moral of the story is be
careful when you have
uh vectors like this
right and you and you're actually like
within the for loop that you're for
reaching over you're modifying this
itself again it's not that apparent
because this is like a whole recursive
hierarchy thing
but
it's very possible obviously that
somewhere within this in this case it
was actually over here but the thing is
this only happens for the first
iteration which is then false
so within this for loop technically we
shouldn't be doing this so i'm not 100
sure why this happens it's possible that
registry destroy which is actually an
ant function maybe within this somewhere
it calls like some kind of
callback and then that callback removes
it
but
overall it's very strange let's kind of
try and wrap let's try and hunt this
down a bit more
so if i go to
uh
and finance it by uhd
okay let's go to destroy
let's go to remove child because we know
that modifies the vector we can see that
it's erasing
the children and well i mean even set
parent does that but like
this doesn't make sense because again it
does this at the very end and it does
this for the first time so i'm not sure
unless it's being indirectly called from
somewhere else let's just try that again
i shouldn't have closed it because then
i could just load it again
but yeah i don't know
a bit weird
oh to be a cat and be chilling on a
massive speaker
that's funny
yeah cats love my massive speakers
it's just a cat's name in russian with a
little cute smile
yep
well yeah alefka he wrote alifka that's
my cat's name
olive but like
it sounds better in russian and i talked
to her in russian because
i mean who wouldn't right uh so if we
bring this back up um well it doesn't
really matter but like if i try and
delete this let's see if that remove
chart see it doesn't even happen
anywhere man so what is modifying it
something is modifying it but it's not
this
so let's not remove child
what what else modifies this children
list
and actually like modifies it though
well the other thing is i guess find
entity by uuid also has to iterate
through no that doesn't really iterate
through children though
this is such a
weird case right because i don't know
what is modifying this list but clearly
us making a copy
fixed it
so that makes me think that yes
something was in fact modifying the list
and there's no like race conditions here
this is all single thread
like all of this work so it's it's
and it was definitely reproducible 100
of the time
so this isn't some weird thing that's
happened this is actually like
something weird is going on and it's
like within like a few functions here
again i might my
my guess is something to do with this
but
but i'm not sure that it is because
like this is the loop that is recursive
so destroy entity calls itself and then
it goes through everything right and
it's not going to have any children in
this case
uh this will be false so it shouldn't be
doing a remove child and
all it's really doing is this i think um
and it doesn't do
it doesn't do a roof child because the
entity itself gets deleted but this
removes itself from
parent if it has a parent but it didn't
even have a parent
so it's all very strange like i
legitimately don't know
what is happening
onscript component destroyed that
doesn't shouldn't do anything with
children
is edit a scene so that's um
uh this is if it's the run time so it's
the runtime we also have to remove it
from physx
uh
but then there's this thing
child id because like the second so
we're iterating through this we have a
child idea we're inside of this iterator
and then we come here and then
we go through everything again and then
we get the iterator again
but the thing is none of this
should be removing it as it like from
the children list right
i mean we can also i guess we can also
put a breakpoint into
here
i mean this happens all the time though
unfortunately okay let's let's um
put a breakpoint here
let's go back to hazel
i'll reload that scene so now we get
sponsored back and we have all of our
entities
and now let's just delete
like this that will trigger this
breakpoint and now i'm going to go to
this children vector
and then
put a breakpoint there
and see what's causing that
so yeah so destroy entity gets it from
here yes
and then
yeah it gets it from there again
and it's always getting it from that
line
line 15 26 which is this
so as far as i can tell that's the only
thing that's getting it
and and like i mean it shouldn't the
iterator itself should be fine because
it's not modifying it it's only reading
it right
like it's never removing children
because that actually happens at the end
like all in one go kind of
oh hang on hang on here's a lambda
ah that's the scene hierarchy panel oh
so we've deleted everything now
think we're done
yeah we're done we just deleted
everything okay let's quickly go back to
what we had
and i want to like
let's just do hsn core
one
child count
so we'll see if this progressively gets
smaller because my guess is this should
always be either 0
or 25
until like the very end
so let's take a look at that
because again my suspicion still is that
something somewhere is probably removing
it like that's kind of the only
explanation that i have
unless i'm just again wrong and i mean
i'm i'm
i'm wrong like
51 of the time so
you've upgraded to the computer
and you've got upgraded to the computer
she can barely barely see but
but she's there
all right we're back
um
so
oh we've already got sponsor look at me
opening it like a full so
uh yeah so we expect this not to work
and as you can see it hasn't deleted
everything so
um
[Music]
so why hasn't it worked let's go to here
where's the delete where did the delete
happen here
child count 125 and all of these are
zeros
yes okay that's not i didn't exactly do
what i wanted though
let's um
i guess what i wanted to do is within
here i want to just verify that my size
is legit
because that because that did it like it
said zero because all of the
all of the
children with no children
so all of the kind of um
leaf nodes they obviously don't have
anything so that's fine but
yeah
log size of children in the loop yep
that's what i'm doing
sorry i haven't been reading chat too
much because i've been too focused
man this startup time though indeed but
i i don't know i was debugging this last
night i was running it in debug mode
same as now but it was way faster so
it's weird i mean now it's also loading
sponsor i guess
whereas before it was loading another
thing but still that this uh startup
time is a bit depressing
we can compare it to release mode in a
minute because that's like a couple
seconds keep trying to load sponsor um
let's delete this and i should stop the
whole rendering entities i keep running
i was just logging how many meshes i was
actually rendering
but yeah so yeah so it's a consistent
25.
the one is because
um the one is because of this because
sponsor has one child which is not zero
just because it happens to be like an
extra parent in the hierarchy in the
actual in the actual fbx file but then
here they are so it's always 25.
so what gives why is it just not
deleting everything or why are these
still here
and why
why are they still here
and why does this fix it
like making it a
making it a cop making a copy of it fix
it the only way that makes any sense is
if something modifies children but
nothing seems to be modifying children
okay new plan
new plan let's make this a for loop
instead of a for each loop right so i'll
make this for
uh i equals zero or let's let's do it
properly size t i
equals zero i is less than
uh we'll get we'll we'll leave that copy
there but
we won't use it size
i plus plus
and then we'll do order
well this is the child id child
we'll just replicate it perfectly so
we'll do child id
equals that and then that's the thing so
same exact thing
but it's a
it's a it's a regular for loop why is
this different because we're just
keeping track of an index now and it's
not dependent it's not like an iterator
and that that is an important
distinction
but if you're on the forward backwards
that's a interesting concept all right
so let's delete this with the ecs debug
panel up oh it worked
excuse me but apparently like
four h loops are just broken is there
like some kind of weird thing where you
can't iterate
you can't get a for each loop within a
for each loop is that a thing
like is that actually a thing in c plus
plus am i not supposed to have a for
each loop inside a for each loop
because i mean well the thing is it
worked when i copy it though
oh but every step of the way copies it
like a nested for each i'm almost
certain it's okay
well yeah i mean i've never run into
this before but that that seems to be
like the
like why is this broken if it's a 4-h
loop
like if it's a range based for loop
so what was it auto child id
and to see children like this
i mean i am retrieving it every time but
that's okay oh
hang on
oh
maybe i figured it out guys
maybe i figured it out
i think what might be happening
is
i'm i'm removing entities from ant
yeah
and i since i'm removing entities from
ant
the component memory might be changing
and so this might be pointing towards
something like it's not necessarily
fixed in memory this thing
obviously when i do this i'm retrieving
it every time
like i'm i'm calling
get component every time but if it's in
a 4h loop like this as an iterator it's
possible that it's not doing that
i'm not even sure how i would test that
i mean i could get the memory address of
it
and see if it's changing i guess
so let's try that
so memory address
and then we'll just get whoops
this
let's let's check this out
this is possible actually because
i'm sure
ant
or entity the lab the entity component
system does some housekeeping
possibly and it could be shifting
components in memory as they get deleted
why don't you just use the normal for
loop well i'm happy to i just want to
find out why this is happening i'm not
satisfied with just being like yeah okay
i guess i guess that's just how it works
because this needs to be an explanation
for it you know as a computer scientist
i'm very much interested in what's going
on
all right so that seems to have worked
uh
so that worked yeah that's fine because
i was using a regular folio but let's
take a look at i'm just printing this
garbage let's take a look at
uh the memory address this one's
different but we expect that one to be
different
oh
no
it's not the same look how many times it
changes
there should be three of these
right no wait
wait why
hold on
okay i know i know a way to test it for
sure this is how we're going to test it
the
this is how we're going to test it so
what we expect
is uh
that
what we expect let's just add a little
level here so in level equals zero
i mean i'll see why i'm doing this now i
i want to see what level because the the
thing is at one given level if we're
iterating over it it should never change
memory address right because obviously
this is a recursive thing which means
that we go deeper and deeper into it
but then obviously if we've stepped into
this function again the children that it
retrieves is for this entity so it is a
different set of children so of course
it would be a different memory address
what we are testing for is that within
the one for loop
this has to be identical this memory
address if it's not then yeah
so the reason we use this level thing is
because we're going to add level plus
one every time we step in recursively
and that way we'll just see like what
level we're at and all that stuff so um
what we'll do is let's just do like
uh l and then i'll write the level here
and then
uh we'll just do address
that
so we would expect the same address
for the same level if they're different
levels then that's fine if they have
different addresses obviously in fact
they they will have different address
they need to have different addresses
because otherwise it doesn't make any
sense so that's my
hypothesis let's test it out alif is
gone
alive
nah she's audi
she's had enough of my
plus debugging right if we bring up uh
unfortunately i'm still printing this
but let's try and delete this now and
then we go back and then again remember
we're looking for same address different
levels rather oh interesting so level
zero we have a one address and then this
you can see the address is constant
until it's not
and we are still at level one
we only move on to in fact we don't even
have a level two
why don't we have level two
oh because
we don't have a level two because they
don't have any children right so these
are all
leaf nodes so that's why we have two
levels
you can see guys that halfway through
this over here
the address changes this is within the
one for loop
and then it changes again
so ent
actually shifts this vector in memory
twice during this iteration thing
that's why it doesn't work
however why our solution works for a
number of reasons is because if we
actually were to copy this like we just
did
if we now look at the memory address of
this child vector
then it will 100 percent be the same it
will not change because we've made a
copy of it and remember none of the
we're not modifying that vector it's
just the physical vector in memory is
moving
we're not modifying the vector at all it
remains size 25 the whole way through
yeah we've we actually tested that
earlier but also i know it's not doing
that because nothing's removing anything
and nothing's clearing the vector it
gets cleared at the very end what
doesn't really get cleared the whole
entity actually gets deleted from memory
along with all of its components and
that vector is inside a component
so that's what's happening so now if we
take a look at this again
delete it and go back to
this quickly i need to stop printing
this
um
let's find it then check this out this
is the difference so see now level zero
has a different vector memory address
but then level one has the same address
the whole way through all 25 entities
that's why it worked
okay
that's why it worked when we made it
when we made a copy of it
so it wasn't because we were modifying
the vector we weren't
it's because the vector was being moved
in memory
and we had that one memory address
reference so if we use a 4h loop it
doesn't work so how do we fix it well
use a a normal for loop why because
every time we use a normal for loop it
calls dot children
yeah so this has a constant size of 25
which is fine we don't that's not going
to change ever that's fine we're safe to
retrieve it like this but then this this
little blob over here we get it each
iteration and since we get it each
iteration
we get the most up-to-date memory
address because going through this code
obviously it looks up the component
inside the registry inside the entity
component system
okay so that's a bit of a tricky bug
definitely a bit of a tricky bug i think
i might make a youtube video out of it
so you guys should say hi to youtube
right now
but um
yeah this is this is definitely a
youtube worthy stream i think it's
probably quite uh satisfying and
interesting to figure out the the bug
but
uh yeah moral of the story be careful
with your memory always think about the
memory because always think about the
data because the data is coming from the
memory and obviously if that moves then
like there's a
a whole kind of situation right so it's
important to kind of be aware of that i
guess so yeah that's the solution i'm
going to leave a note here
no don't don't make an engine